so what do you know about jada and well
so far
according to you they were the power
couple they were they're married 20
years have these two kids right
in love everyone
will always talk about sticking it out
with your woman
he'd always be like showing her off like
this
you see
i see
power couple everyone loved them
but me i always thought something was
off about them because of their kids
okay
and i had this thought before everyone
else had this thought
okay because these are their children
okay they have they have three kids i
thought they had two
oh i think this kid is from a different
marriage with will but these these two
kids they had together
but like they're always into like
alternative lifestyle and like
non-monogamy and that stuff and i just
thought like something was weird
because like will was this white house
picket fence type of guy and i'm like
why are his kids
into this stuff
yeah does that make sense i'm like what
what is weird so
the manosphere does a little bit of
digging right
let me make sure this is still working
fine
um
okay it is the manosphere does a little
bit of digging and
jada also let me know if the audio is
okay in the chat
and tupac
okay okay wait turn off the
so this is jada's ex-boyfriend do you
know who tupac is
yeah did you name a cat after him
i did have a cat that i named tupac that
is that is true
i forgot i did that
yeah it was dumb dumb and tupac
i love tupac is one of my favorite cats
[ __ ] ran away i know
when i went to college i came dumbledore
is still here
dumbledore is a great cat i think tupac
is hating because he ran away right
after they got off their ringworm
medication oh i think he just like hated
the medication okay so
i'm gonna show you
youtube
um
tupac
i want to show you how jada would talk
about tupac
[Applause]
oh no not there
the heartbreaking okay this one
[Music]
i mean can you guys hear that in the
chat let me just double check that the
desktop audio is working
yeah let me know in the chat if it's not
i think it is but let me
just
[Music]
in a recent episode of red table talk
jada interviewed robin crawford about
her relationship with whitney
but what was also revealing was what
jada shared about her friendship with
tupac shakur
it's hard to
love someone who you know has had a
legacy
at the level that
she has had
and then to lose them
under tragic circumstances because i
have a very similar situation
many speculated for years
that jada and park dated but jada said
that couldn't have been further from the
truth
rather their relationship was more like
an older brother stroke sister
relationship or even that of a father
and daughter
she implied that their relationship ran
deeper than any physical relationship
ever could
tupac and jada met at the baltimore
school of performing arts
they remained close friends right up
until his tragic death in 1996. it was
the first day
and he came over to me and introduced
himself
and in high school park was a little
funny looking
definitely from looking at him wasn't
necessarily the type of cat that i would
even like
deal with
but as soon as he approached me he was
like a magnet once you paid attention to
him he kind of sucked you in
and we hit it i wish i could find the
actual actual um video where she's like
talking about him
but
let's see
oh look at this one
whatever jealous of the love jada had
for tupac okay so this is this is will
smith and they're talking about like
jada's like tupac okay uh oh [ __ ] yeah
god damn dude and you know that was in
uh that was in the early days yeah i was
in the early days and it was like
um that's that was a big regret for me
too because i could never
um i could never open up to interact
with with poc
you know and because we had a little bit
of a thing right because you know um
you know they grew up together
and you know they loved each other but
they never had that you know they never
had a sexual relationship but they had
come into that age where now that was a
possibility and then jada was with me
you know so you know park had a little
thing on that um but she just loved him
like he was the image of perfection but
she was with the fresh prince you know
so it was like i i just i never could
like even we were in a room together a
couple times i couldn't speak to him you
know and you know he wasn't going to
speak to me if i wasn't going to speak
to him but somebody would have so much
in common no that's what jada was saying
all the time she was like i'm telling
you y'all are so similar you will you
love him and i just never you know that
that that was a huge regret of mine i
just didn't i couldn't i couldn't handle
it you know i was just i was the soft
rapper from philly and he was pock right
what do you think of that so far
it's like how he feels yeah like what do
you think of jada and tupac's
relationship
i think it seems like they were dating
very clearly seems like they were dating
and do you think that um
tupac is
like do you think jada wanted to be with
tupac or wanted to be with will
i think it's definitely tupac but
tupac's dead
yeah
so and then like you'll see videos of
jada like talking about tupac and this
is like years later
like talking about how much she like
loved him and stuff
like here this is another one
a lot of people
you know talk about my relationship with
poc and trying to figure that out you
know and that was a huge loss in my life
absolutely
yeah
because he was one of those people that
i expected to be here and my upset is
more anger
you know what i'm saying because i feel
that
he left me
and i know that's not true and it's a
very selfish way to think about it but
i really did believe that he was going
to be here for the long run right
so how does how does this sound
regretful it's kind of like it kind of
sounds like like she's still in love
with him doesn't it
yeah
and which is crazy because will smith
can have anybody
anybody
you know i would do to be you think
wilson is hot right oh yeah
i would drop all my hoes will
okay i don't have any hoes but
but if i did i would drop them i would
drop them okay so then then okay so
this is going on right they're the power
couple they have the two kids
and
in the past year
um i don't know when when did the jada
and
anyone know in the chat when the jada
okay let me do jada entanglement
okay okay so then this
so for years they're the power couple as
brightest everyone loves them
the world changes
their view on them with this
this clip in 2020 so this is like two
years ago now
they're seen as this like all-american
perfect family jada pinkett smith
brought herself to the red table and
surprisingly her husband will smith
joined her they talked about pain
healing and yes jada's entanglement with
august alcena it's all love recently al
cena revealed to the world that he was
involved in a relationship with jada
while she was still married and even
though statements were released denying
the affair pinkish smith is now
reluctantly confirming that the
relationship did indeed exist it's a
situation that i
consider private you just feel like it
ain't really nobody nobody's business
yeah but yeah
but now black twitter has claimed it as
they business during the 12-minute red
table talk episode jada sat down with
will to explain how she met august four
and a half years ago but the friendship
didn't turn into something more until
she and will were ready to call it quits
you and i were going through a very
difficult time yeah
and we decided i was done with you yeah
you kicked me to the curb with you yeah
marriages have that though
yeah we basically we broke up and then
what did you do jada well you know i
think
from there
you know as time went on i got into a
different kind of entanglement
with august yes we know entanglement is
vague as hell but thankfully will
pressed her to be more clear than
entanglement yes
yes a relationship yes it was a
relationship absolutely we also got
clarity on the misconception that will
gave august permission to sleep with his
wife the only person that could give
permission in in that particular
circumstance is myself yes exactly yeah
but what
august was probably trying to
communicate
because i could actually see how he
would perceive it as
permission because we were
separated amicably
and
i think he also wanted to make it clear
that he's not a homewrecker now if
you're like us you're probably wondering
why august well we'll let jada explain
it i just wanted to feel good
it had been so
long
since i felt
good
and it was really a joy
to just
help heal somebody eventually august
broke things off and they haven't really
talked since and the smith's claim they
are now stronger than ever we
ride together we go together
bad marriage for life
okay what are you thinking
[Laughter]
what do you think of that
she seemed like she was making a lot of
excuses for
right
like
she wasn't faithful yeah like she wanted
he wanted to feel something like enough
like what kind of feel something you
talking about man
maybe invite her to our talk from last
night
in our talk from last night
yeah jada you can you can do a couch
a couch discussion with me and my sister
okay so
then after this happens the last two
years
everyone's been making fun of will
like why is he this man can have anybody
why is he putting up with this
right this is why i say guys some men
prefer women that are mean to them and i
swear to god i have seen this i don't
know what it is
but
like this guy has all the options he
could have dated margot robbie let's be
real he could uh
you see them in that movie he coulda
but he chooses to put up with this
as a man why
why like is she that special like what
so
then he becomes the butt of all the
jokes like
let me let me see if i can find one
um
should we go to
twitter
jada will
ah
let's see i think there was
some twitter oh no it's only gonna be
the new one
but like
people would like clip that video and be
like well are you good at
all this stuff is like brought into the
limelight
and like even kevin samuels who's like
the father of like
they call it the manosphere it's kind of
here hold on
will
jada
kevin samuels
okay this is
this is like what this is the guy who's
like the godfather of the man of sphere
they call him
okay
[Music]
cause
[Music]
a lot better than they are at the smith
compound
why
would you say that godfather well
because it's often been rumored
that will and jada were in kind of an
open marriage situation
and uh
look coming from my line of business
that's not new news these things happen
all the time with rich people but you
know
i want to let will and jada explain it
themselves
so
before we
get into let's get into the broadcast
because in case you haven't heard it
i'll let you hear it straight from
the horse's mouth herself
and let's go ahead and
and mind you everyone's talking about
this he's just one of like many people
making videos like
candlelight lighting
and let's hear from will and jada
themselves
uh
oh
this
red table for me
um
just all the stuff that's going on
i felt like it was important to come to
the table to really clear the air
somebody made a statement for me that
wasn't a statement i made
that went
cray-cray and one of the reasons why
i wanted to come to the table is the
media the headlines
we specifically never said anything yeah
we were purposely not saying anything
any headline that says jada said or will
said or the smith said it's not true
we've specifically never said anything
right so coming to the table was like we
just felt like
it got to the point where you guys say
something yeah and and to stop that
cycle yeah you know there's people's
feelings involved right
right you know and at the end of the day
i don't like how all of this came to be
that doesn't matter
it's all love
honestly and i would usually not
you know that that would be something i
wouldn't comment on at all yeah you know
and i feel like
it's a situation that i could consider
private you just feel like it ain't
really nobody no nobody's business yeah
but yeah
but now black twitter has claimed it as
they business
but you know that's the thing i think
with marriages like [ __ ] always comes
out eventually
yeah there's too many people especially
if you're like on the streets and stuff
there's like even lebron james everyone
look at him as the perfect
husband but there's even like
accounts of him cheating and stuff like
i don't know the streets always talk
guys
sooner or later the streets talk i feel
like it's it's healing that needs to
happen
and i know there's a lot of stuff going
on in the world right now yeah even
though this is minuscule i do feel like
it's these kinds of things that create
the world that we're in and the idea of
not communicating
not talking about it not clearing the
air and just being as transparent
just being transparent and i'm i'm here
with you yeah i thank you for that
because you've been on a hell of a
journey with me so that's what we're
going to start with this is a very
personal journey yeah that became very
public yes absolutely for whatever
reason so what happened jada okay so
let's start with
i guess about
four and a half years ago
started a i think it was about four and
a half four years ago
um
started a friendship with august
a friendship
do you do you hook up with your friends
very clearly no
i don't either ma'am
ma'am
and we actually became really really
good guitar in your way i can move it if
it's in your way
any chance the slap was staged we'll get
into that later we're not there yet i'm
giving my sister doesn't know about any
of this stuff so i'm updating her good
friends and it all started with
him just needing some help
you know
me wanting to help his
health his
mental state and he i think he was
addicted to like drugs
and stuff i think that so when she's
saying like i wanted to help don't don't
touch the mic it'll it'll um
make it too loud for the audience but
does that make sense so he was like a
drug addict
because for me that was the thing when i
um when ogg first came around he was he
was really sick he was really really
sick yeah and
the
output alcohol for him from our family
was
initially about his health yeah
and i mean first will's helping the man
out
at first will's taking the man in we
found all those different resources you
know to
help pull them through and
from there you know you and i were going
through a very
difficult time yeah
and we decided i was done with your life
yeah you kicked me to the curb with you
yeah
yeah we basically we broke up we decided
that we were going to
separate for a period of time and you go
figure out how to make yourself happy
and i'll figure out how to what do you
think when people say that like i need
to figure out how to make myself happy
do you think that's like a real thing
and reason to leave a marriage
i think that if you're not happy in the
marriage when you figure out how to make
yourself happy you're going to be out of
the marriage
like
yeah do you think people just say that
when they want to leave loki like what's
up they don't want to say that they want
to leave
[Music]
it's like a break
okay okay okay
what friends
oh
well at that particular point in time it
was indefinite yeah i really felt like
we could be over
yeah no we were over and then what did
you do jada well you know i think
from there
you know as time went on i got into a
different kind of entanglement
with august and one thing i want to get
clear about and clean up one of the
things that was kind of swirling in the
press about you giving permission which
is
uh
you know the only person that can give
permission in in that particular
circumstances myself yes exactly yeah
but what august was probably trying to
communicate
because i could actually see how he
would perceive it as
permission because we were
separated amicably
and i think he also wanted to make it
clear that he's not a homewrecker
which he's not i'm thinking so i mean
because this is do you think he's a
homewrecker
august yeah no i think jada is yeah
well but i think it's kind of dirty if
someone like imagine okay imagine
i don't want to use this example with
our family
but you can think of some people that
we've taken in right because our family
does that like we always take in
strays right
now imagine if one of the strays hooked
up with mom
after dad took him in
like the level of disrespect
yeah like that's that's that's so
disrespectful it's disrespectful but
jadis still like
yeah they have to you have to be in the
marriage to wreck it yeah no for sure
but i i don't i still think that's dirty
but we'll continue your red table and
you like brought yourself to the red
table
i think um you need to say clearly what
happened as far as what you and i
decided we were gonna
take our space and what happened yeah
and then i got into an entanglement with
august that's what i said an
entanglement yes
yes a relationship yes it was a
relationship absolutely i was in a lot
of pain and i was very broken
now in the process of that relationship
i definitely realized that
you can't find happiness outside of
yourself bear you
okay do you think
that
if the tables were turned and a girl a
guy did the same thing he said i was
really broken
and he hooked up with a 20 year old
drug addict
do you think people would how do you
think people would perceive that do you
think it'd be different than a girl
doing the same thing
yeah i'd be very negatively will get
canceled yeah
like isn't that crazy but like she
doesn't get cancelled when she she like
she's kind of taking advantage of a guy
who's like addicted to drugs
yeah
it's not
that kind of nuts
it continues and luckily enough
you and i were also going through a
process of healing in a much different
manner i would definitely say and we did
everything that we could to get away
from each other only to realize that
that wasn't
possible so we coming to the rear table
so i'm in i'm in the jaded position
right now so you know you
during that time launched into
an interaction
with august what do you feel like
interaction and tango you were looking
for
i just wanted to feel good
it had been so
long
since i felt
good
and it was really a joy to just
will i will take her place
you can cheat on me
[Music]
oh
hannah you should be ashamed of yourself
i'm just kidding
yeah
no three kids is a lot
they're older but for you will sorry i'm
done i think that has a lot to do with
my
codependency
which is another thing that i had to
learn to break in this cycle just that
idea of needing to fix and being drawn
to people that need help whether it's
your health or whether it's your
addictions there's something i think i
have that a little bit in me i think us
davises we kind of like strays a little
bit
[Laughter]
i don't know about me yet but you
it's not just me it's our other siblings
too why is that yeah i mean adam did
bring chaz home one day and then
he did
we do be
bringing people home
i i had my last boyfriend moved in with
us
yeah sorry i i relate a little bit not
not that much no no drug addicts about
that childhood trauma
um that
feels as though it can be fixed
through
fixing people
versus
fixing me yeah
and i think that that whole process what
do you think of what she's saying so far
a lot of excuses for
trying to like she's trying to say i
cheated in fancy terms
see
eve is my little hippie sister but she's
not stupid
calling me a hippie
what should i call you
she's not looking she's wearing tie-dye
it's scooby-doo
scooby doo
a crime fighting show
i rest my case
really showed me that
and taught me that
and i'm really grateful for that lesson
i feel like that husband
like i'm with you at the press
conference
and that husband now i got to be with
you at the press conference while you
like to tell the world
about your transgressions
well like i love i love my baby i'ma
stand by my baby no matter what well you
know i think that's right he should
stand by his baby no matter what no
do you think that love is conditional
yeah yeah do you think if you're being
treated like [ __ ] you should you think
if you get cheated on you should leave
i think it depends okay what do you
think it depends on
like the conditions of cheating like if
they just cheated like
you know
really
that's interesting well i think when you
have kids it's not about you anymore so
i understand that but your kids are
grown i don't think they're grown yet i
think they're like 12.
no they're they're older i think they're
over 18.
but the thing is like
i feel like
at some point like i think jada was kind
of a bad influence on the kids because i
see like the way they grew up and i just
don't get that coming from well i mean
they are old like all the like open
relationships and that type of stuff
like i just that seems like a jada
like new age thing yeah which i guess
some people might be for that just i
personally wouldn't want my kids like
being raised around that type of stuff
or watching the mother of your kids f a
20 year old one of and like the thing is
i bet willow knew because that's her
friend it was like her daughter's friend
yeah
like imagine imagine if will aft his
daughter's friend
wouldn't that be nuts
be nasty
i definitely i definitely understand um
why it would look that way or feel that
way but i actually don't look at it as a
transgression at all through that
particular journey i learned so much
about myself and was able to really
confront a lot of
emotional immaturity emotional
insecurity and i was really able
to do some really deep healing
you know and as i came through and
started to realize certain things about
you and i he decided
to
break all communication with me right
which was totally understandable right
um and i let that be and hadn't talked
to him since right so it is a little
weird that all this stuff is coming out
now since this was yeah because for me
that's right what did she say
wait what did you how did it end did you
hear that no
okay wait i just want to see
as a transgression at all through that
particular journey i learned so much
about myself and was able to really
confront a lot of
emotional immaturity emotional
insecurity and i was really able
to do some really deep healing
you know and as i came through and
started to realize certain things about
you and i he decided
to
break all communication with me right
which was totally understandable right
um
and i let that be and had him so he like
pumped and dumped
and talked to him since right so it is a
little weird that all this why do they
call it deep healing
like why do girls do this
i don't know hannah how did you heal by
getting ran through
like what
how does that make you a better person
you're you're asking me
don't do that if you get married someday
don't do that coming out now since this
was yeah because for me this was years
ago right you know so the fact that it's
uh coming up now and i think it could
feel weird for people that we're
laughing and and talking about it but it
happened so long ago you know and
our experiences of working through it
fighting through it talking through it
and
therapizing right through it i think
that the why now is weird yeah when i
say it's been a huge healing on my life
and just what i had to confront and
discover
you know about myself
the ugly truths
and the beauty
so it was what are you talking about
lady
what
the ugly truth of getting [ __ ] down
like
something that i felt like wasn't really
you want your tea i want my tea okay
here you go
ready to be discussed because it hadn't
been that
healing because he hasn't wanted to
you know og and i haven't talked in
okay i'm gonna like fast forward to
where
kevin samuels talks marriage is hard
welcome to real world stuff folks
welcome to real world stuff
if this is your first time seeing that
understand something that is far more
the norm
when it comes to power couples people
who marry and people who stay together
for a long time if you know anything
about your grandma and grandfather you
probably still find out stuff that you
didn't know
you probably met some uh half brothers
and stuff at funerals
you know when you're
on the other side of town i was telling
people
but this is far more uh far more common
than a lot of us like to think but my
real question is this
that was grandma and grandpa
i want to fast forward up to
grandma and grandpa are gone they're
dead that was the silent generation
after them it was the baby boomers
and the baby boomers are people from
like 56
uh to around 70
are my parents boomers
how old's dad
[Laughter]
mom and dad are in their 50s
well i think mom's like 52 dad's 57
maybe
they're five years apart mom yes dad's
57 that's gross
okay
eight dads like an elder
baby boomers
those people are still alive
but the late baby boomers those are the
people from like 56 to 62
all of generation x which is from 40 to
56 and then late millennials from 36
to 40.
i gotta ask the question
do these black women really want to be
married
uh if you go back
in your memory
alicia keys
did a song that everybody thought was
just so great
unbreakable
we could fight like i can tina
or give it back like bill and camille
the cosby's
be rich like oprah and steadman
or ins or instead struggle like flo and
james evans
we could act it out like will and jada
or like kamara and russell
making paper
all in the family like the jacksons like
the jacksons and even have enough kids
to make i can't i just want to go to the
part where he talks about
okay i can't find it because kevin
samuel's broadcast for so long but
basically
he says that will was jada's second
choice
and you can kind of hear how she talks
about tupac like she wanted to be with
tupac
and she like feels like she settled for
will would you agree with that like
based on what you've seen
yeah yeah
like um and so
like
basically like the whole world is
talking about this because this is eva
you don't even understand this is like a
cultural moment like people love jaden
willin i called this
mom mom loves will smith and i said to
mom before any of this came out i said
something weird is going on in that
house because
there is no way they should be like this
young and so open to like open
relationships
like even even the people in our family
right
if you're 16 in an open relationship
and and you're telling the world about
this people do weird [ __ ] when they're
young but it's like the culture like
when it's coming from your their family
you can tell because it's like
like they'll be like 16 17 and publicly
talking about this
you know what i'm saying like i don't
think anyone in our family
would do like a full-on like open
relationship and if they did they sure
as hell wouldn't go on a public platform
and say
like it had to be something in the
family would you agree with that
yeah like that had to be something with
how they were raised so i called this i
called i didn't know how far it went but
i was like there is something weird
going on in that family
okay so now this brings us so two years
of this this brings us to last night